I want to talk a little bit about a
critical race Theory protest gone
completely Haywire in Ashburn Virginia
the school board of this wealthy County
Loudoun County in Virginia I wanted to
hold a meeting to close out the school
year and it became complete and total
chaos in this Washington DC suburb as
parents who apparently are against
critical race Theory although it's not
completely clear they really know what
it is they wanted to protest critical
race Theory we're going to look at some
video clips here this is wild wild stuff
here is one parent
um the founder of parents against
critical race Theory speaking to a crowd
outside the event take a listen to this
changing an area political race theory
is cultural responsive framework
culturally responsive teaching it's all
just Trojan horses
inequity diversity and inclusion you
know come on you know one thing yeah who
would want any of that stuff guys I mean
that's just crazy it's crazy what
they're trying to teach now I I am a
Critic of critical race Theory
um that this you know we one of the
things that happens in Academia is you
have a theory and then you have
critiques of the theory and that's all
normal and good uh but we don't we don't
want to teach inclusion we don't want to
teach the value of equality I mean it's
he doesn't even really seem to
understand what critical race theory is
then of course they broke into the
national anthem listen to this
you
feel that the Twilight
I think you get the the impression this
is not it's it's they're just standing
in the parking lot singing the National
Anthem again if you were to satire
um sort of like ignorant clueless uh
protests of critical race Theory this is
what they would look like
um then the crowd inside the event
wouldn't shut up and they had to
threaten to end the meeting disgusting
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
so there were threats that if these
people don't quiet down they're gonna
have to end the meeting and then they
did actually end the public comment
section and people went completely nuts
[Music]
[Music]
so that was after the announcement that
they were going to have to wrap the
thing up because people were going
completely crazy
um and things just continued getting
Wilder and Wilder take a look
oh this is when they go back into the
national anthem the the meeting was
ended and they go back into the national
anthem
Dear God
[Music]
so that went on and then
um then the arrest started happening uh
here is you will this is while an arrest
is going on you I think in this clip you
hear someone yell who pays your salary
to the police officers as well
there it is
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay so people getting completely
outraged I guess they're mad at
everything getting mad at the police
getting mad at the the school board
getting mad at the T everybody's furious
with everybody and then this is sort of
like the cherry on top here is a guy uh
getting getting himself arrested in the
midst of this
[Music]
foreign
by the way you know we we talk about
resisting arrest is used as a catch-all
when police want to manhandle someone
um by the standards we normally see
apply to what counts as resisting arrest
this guy's doing it and police treating
him very very politely as you can tell
him
[Music]
it's not over I love how the guy says
the the officer says the meeting is over
and the guy says it's not you can see if
you're watching the video that there's
almost no one left so the meeting
clearly is over I think that's more of
an empirical question the meeting has
ended but just another complete and
total humiliation and this is sort of a
mind virus this is an example of where
the idea of critical race Theory as an
indoctrination strategy in high schools
has spread like a virus among some of
these right Wingers and they can no
longer think sensibly they can no longer
behave like adults it's a real sad thing
to see but they seem to have really
latched on to this in a pretty serious
way I don't expect this to go away
anytime soon and we may do even a deep
dive on critical race Theory at some
point in the next few weeks because it
is becoming I mean listen these are
adults supposedly and look at what the
idea the Misunderstood idea that they
have of course critical race theory has
done to them I'm all for serious
critiques of critical race Theory I've
done them I think it's reductive and I I
think it's not uh the type of of theory
that will further race relations but I'm
not going to be showing up uh and
getting myself arrested and screaming I
I'm just glad to talk to people about it
in a calm sensible and rational way I
don't expect this to end anytime soon
we'll have some more of these clips on
the show's Instagram which you can find
at David Pacman show you can also find
me on Instagram at david.pakman we'll
take a quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies I've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews and best of all if you
don't love it you'll get 100 of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try four sigmatic is
giving my audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash Pacman the link
is right underneath this video